[Musique]
première chronique de 2023 vous
comprendrez que si j'ai fini enseveli
avant la fin de cette chronique c'est
qu'il neige mais une personne qui se
peintre pas d'être ensevelie si James
Cameron l'inspiration derrière ma
chronique d'aujourd'hui car je pense que
c'est à partir de cette semaine il
risque de franchir le cap des 2
milliards de dollars que le film Avatar
2 va avoir produit depuis sa sortie
autant des fêtes et c'est complètement
fou bien sûr c'est pas une question
d'argent pourquoi je veux parler cette
chronique c'est toute la conversation
autour de l'appropriation culturelle le
Blue face et aussi le White Saver
complexe complexe du Sauveur blanc qui
ont été des sujets de conversation qui
ont beaucoup circulé dans mes médias
sociaux pendant le temps des fêtes et
bien sûr écoutez vous pouvez imaginer
qu'est-ce qu'on dit on peut plus rien
dire on peut plus rien faire on peut
même plus faire des histoires inventées
de la fiction ils voient du racisme
partout j'ai vu ça aussi mais j'ai aussi
vu approviation culturelle c'est du vol
où est-ce que c'est mignon de dollars
c'est milliards à l'époque c'était des
millions maintenant c'est des milliards
à l'époque c'est où est-ce que c'est
milliards de dollars le vent c'est quand
même pas dans la poche des personnes
autochtones qui ont inspiré beaucoup de
la culture visuelle dans le film
alors je vais essayer de décortiquer
très rapidement parce que on pourrait
passer à un an sur juste l'analyse de
film là parce que ce qui va arriver dans
quelques mois quand ce film là va avoir
fait tellement de milliards je sais
comment Titanic avait provoqué tellement
de documentaires j'espère que Avatar va
provoquer des conversations mais pour
commencer on va y aller avec la
propriation culturelle clairement
clairement le film Avatar le premier et
le film Avatar 2 avait été inspiré par
des cultures autochtones qui se trouvent
sur cette planète ci sur la planète
Terre faut comprendre que si on se
retrouvait dans une
une vraie planète avec des vrais Navy
clairement que leur
culture serait pas humano centriste elle
serait probablement inspirée de leur
propre planète et là on voit clairement
des pratiques dans le Avatar 2 des
tatouages faciaux on voit aussi la
pratique chez les
excusez-moi mais les Maoris de sortir la
langue pour pouvoir intimider les
personnes en face de soi il y a toutes
ces pratiques clairement culturellement
qui viennent de la planète Terre qui se
sont retrouvés je ne sais pas comment
sur une planète remplie d'êtres humains
bleus mais clairement c'est inspiré des
communautés autochtones et bien sûr il y
a un discussion autour de ça parce que
comment est-ce qu'une femme qui
clairement inspirée la culture maori
peut être jouée par Kate Winslet une
Anglaise pourquoi est-ce que telle
personnage tout d'un coup ils mettent
des rasters c'est vraiment de dire que
il y a eu une discussion trop de ça sauf
que un des arguments qui clairement
ressortait beaucoup c'est ils existent
pas les navires c'est un peuple qui est
inventé par James Cameron pour faire un
film de fiction on peut plus rien dire
parce que même quand on invente des
peuples
clairement ils vont crier au racisme
mais c'est juste que en tant que
communauté autochtone on reconnaît les
codes culturels autochtones qu'on voit
dedans et donc c'est très dur de pas
dire
appropriation mais comme l'appropriation
culturelle est portée souvent dans des
grands groupes on peut pas la défendre
comme du vol de bien intellectuel le
propriétaire intellectuel comme si tu
voyais un bout de ma chanson ou si tu
copies un des design de mes vêtements je
pourrais te poursuivre en cours pour
voir le propriétaire intellectuelle mais
quand c'est une culture un groupe et que
cette culture là a été
copié-coller sur dans un film
c'est difficile je peux pas encore dire
si tous les designers étaient
autochtones si il y a eu des discussions
qui ont été faites avec les communautés
mais c'est très difficile de voir
clairement une conversation qui a eu
lieu avec des communautés qui ont servi
à inspirer le film Avatar donc pour
l'instant ça reste un gros point
d'interrogation et je vais donner le
bénéfice du doute
mais c'est certain que moi en tant que
personne qui a vu le film ce qui
m'intéressait plus que l'histoire
derrière
Jake Sully et bien c'était de voir plus
de culture autochtones comment ils ont
développé l'idée des cultures
autochtones dans le film et là ce que je
voulais c'est un copier-coller donc je
me dis ah j'aimerais savoir comment ils
ont imaginé les nazis qui vivent dans le
Grand Nord c'est parce que sûrement un
pôle Nord dans ce dans cette planète là
est-ce que c'est juste des montres
tropicaux ou est-ce qu'il y a des
personnes qui vivent dans des déserts
donc ça ça m'intéressait beaucoup plus
dans le film et c'est pas la langue
qu'on a exploité le plus et là c'est là
où est-ce que j'arrive avec après
culturelle et le blueface c'est le
la partie du Sauveur blanc du complexe
du Sauveur blanc et c'est que toute
l'histoire comme danse avec Lilou comme
justement l'histoire de pocahontasu au
tourne autour d'un homme blanc qui vient
et qui pour des raisons très évidentes
se retrouvent avec le héros et non
seulement le héros dans ce coup-ci mais
il devient l'espèce de sauveur mais si
en plus de cette population là
tous les problèmes et en plus ils
deviennent lui-même un avis bien sûr le
film me fait en sorte qu'à la fin du
film il était un avis maintenant il y a
son esprit avec des transposés dans le
corps bleu qui avait été
bio ingénieriée pour par l'armée donc
vous comprenez que le Sauveur blanc le
complexe du Sauveur blanc c'est un
complexe existe beaucoup face à la
culpabilité
au lié au colonialisme liés aux effets
de la colonisation on peut penser par
exemple
aux personnes qui sentent mal par
rapport à l'esclavage on peut passer à
ceux qui se sentent mal par rapport aux
enfants qui ont été dans les pensionnats
tout ça amène une culpabilité et souvent
plutôt que d'avoir la discussion je peux
avoir la réparation on va essayer de
sauter par-dessus et essayer de dire
mais regardez je suis votre allié je
suis votre ami et la discussion était
facile au profit de ne pas vouloir
froisser les ou comment je peux dire
l'ego de la personne en face de nous et
dans ce cas-ci bien c'est Jake Solly qui
devient le super Navy mais plus la vie
encore que les navies puisqu'il est
connecté de façon hyper mais ça
l'amenait aussi d'autres sujets de
conversation très intéressant par
rapport à
la rencontre de deux
identités culturelles dans ce que si
carrément
d'espèce et c'est encore une
conversation qui est très difficile à
aborder même dans celui-là je le voyais
ouh c'est c'est pas clair mais ça ce que
ce qui est bien et ce qui est très
ironique en même temps parce que c'est
vraiment je parle beaucoup à partir de
l'ironie c'est que le film qui a amené
le plus de milliards présentement
télévision il va pas être des records
c'est clair
c'est un film sur les effets de la
colonisation la destruction du
territoire et ça a été fait par des
compagnies par des personnes qui ont été
justement
elle aussi des personnes qui ont amené
la colonisation du vol intellectuel de
l'appropriation culturelle et donc cette
conversation a devient un peu à
plusieurs niveaux c'est comme si on
voulait montrer patte blanche on a fait
un film sur la colonisation mais on
n'est pas encore capable d'avoir la
discussion ou la réparation autour de la
colonisation donc James Cameron moi les
questions que j'y poserai c'est est-ce
que vous avez pensé justement à toutes
les idéologies autour des communautés
autochtones qui sont ici est-ce que ça a
vraiment été discuté avec des personnes
autochtones ou avec des anthropologues
qui viennent de communautés autochtones
surtout des intérêts que moi j'ai en
tant que personne que vu le film c'est
certain que je suis comme tout le monde
je veux dire j'ai vu le film je pense
deux fois au cours de du temps des fêtes
j'ai trouvé magnifique mais ce que je me
suis dit c'est
il y a aucune personne autochtone qui
aurait pu faire ce film là même s'il
avait voulu même s'il y avait eu des
meilleures idées encore parce que on
était encore dans la décolonisation des
systèmes dans la décolonisation des
entreprises et tous les privilèges qui
ont été accumulés par non seulement la
culture les ancêtres et James Cameron
lui ont permis de pouvoir produire ce
film là mais pour l'instant ceux qui
sont autochtones commencent à peine à
justement poindre à l'horizon et là je
fais un gros clin d'oeil à tycao-ity qui
fait je travaille là mais qui est encore
justement soumis aux limites de ce que
le cinéma américain va bien lui
permettre donc est-ce que un jour on va
pouvoir avoir cette discussion difficile
là par rapport à la représentation par
rapport au cinéma par rapport aussi à
quand on fait une histoire qui est
inspiré clairement de la colonisation
puis du vol culturel des communautés
autochtones est-ce que ça un jour
revenir en réparation dans les
communautés permettent justement créer
un centre culturel pour chaque
communauté qui a participé à ces films
là pour leur permettre de défaire les
effets de la colonisation etc et est-ce
que justement les idées l'imagination
autochtone qui elle ne rentre pas encore
dans ça et qui va rentrer aussi dans une
critique par rapport à la culture
va-t-elle être ouverte permissive est-ce
qu'on va réussir à dépasser justement le
baba de des autochtones des allochtones
est-ce qu'on va
on va se laisser encore plus inspirer
mais d'une façon qui respectueuse et qui
ne s'approprie pas la culture des autres
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on n'ira pas le
voir c'est pas dire qu'il y a des gens
qui qui ne seront pas complètement en
amour avec ce film là c'est juste que
c'est des conversations qui sont très
intéressantes à avoir et qui ne doivent
pas être effacées quand il y a une
critique par le fait que d'autres
autochtones sont allés voir et on peut
du tout eu la même lecture que moi par
exemple sur le film et ça c'est très
difficile parce qu'on va souvent essayer
de tokeniser la voix de ceux qui ont un
film qui ont pas d'appréhension
culturelle autour
du cinéma pour effacer la voix de ceux
qui en sont très critiques donc vous
comprenez que je pars 2023 avec
babyphone mais aussi avec encore une
fois beaucoup de questionnements sur le
futur qu'on a ensemble et je pense que
je commence à être dans ce lit alors je
vais vous souhaiter une belle journée et
on se voit à la prochaine